[Musik]
etwas knapp netz bekommen beim ein video
ihr seht wahrscheinlich ich habe heute
zwei fremde gäste die waren noch nie
dabei also hier ist einfach erst mal
steht man jetzt welche freunde einmal
mein rennen und mein bruder dass ich
meine freunde und ich will eigentlich
gar nicht lange lagern aber jetzt schon
wir haben halt alle was ähnliches an
also und zwar ganz kurz vorweg sofort
mit dem richtigen wieder losgeht ich
habe mir gedacht es kann man noch mal
ein video wo ich das halt wirklich so
ein bisschen ausführlicher erkläre aber
works hin oder her dass jetzt auch noch
geben aber ich hab mir gelassen ich
hatte da einfach viel mit bock drauf du
meine eigenen klamotten mit dem eigenen
namen zu machen und diese jetzt zum teil
der schock dazu ist genau jetzt online
gegangen
ihr könnt auf jeden fall mal in die
wiederbeschaffung klicken euch da mal
ein bisschen durchstöbert oder so
vielleicht gefällt es auch alles
wirklich sehr sehr günstig gehalten als
ich will niemanden da ergibt mehr zu den
pulli da wirklich nur höchstens 30 euro
wert ist 540 euro dazu also erstens
nicht über 30 euro keine arme mehr will
ich ganz sagen der instagram macau dazu
auch unten in der video beschreibung
könnt ihr gerne folgen da kommen echt
coole bilder mit diesen ganzen klamotten
natürlich auch von euch wenn ihr die
trag könnte mir das zwicken an bord war
das da und hier an sich bin ich ziemlich
zufrieden mir gefällt ich hoffe euch
auch zum teil
und jetzt fangen wir an mit dem video
ist zu lang
momentan steht nachher wieder die etwa
30 ja aber ich wusste ja darauf
aufmerksam machen mit mir hinten sitzen
heute ist video wir machen folgendes und
zwar hab ich mir gedacht jetzt dorf vom
leben haben wir aber meine freunde und
mein bruder und ich denn jetzt
vielleicht fragen komplett über mit und
im mittelalter macht er mich besser
kennt eingriffen zehn fragen ja schnell
raus und jemand wirklich sofort auf die
frage antworten und werde dann richtig
mit klickraten punkt mal gucken wir an
den folgetagen der verlierer krieg dann
zehn schläge ins gesicht
eine ganz einfache bestrafung dafür den
schlägen war natürlich nur ein spaß ich
hoffe ihr seid alle gut vorbereitet und
dann sehen wir gewinnen und ich habe
erst mal gedacht ich fange mit einer
ganz einfachen frage an welchem tag im
september wenn ich geworden
er hat jetzt männer geworden mit
wievielen jahr habe ich angefangen
fußball zu spielen
6 4 4 6
ich dachte man ein schwarzer musiker die
stadt sogar eigentlich beispiel mit drei
jahren angefangen doch er konnte schon
schließlich laufen die friedlichste
kochen möchte frage wer all das ist
jetzt ein 1 0 wer war mein bester freund
in der grundschule männer hat mir der
russe wand war früher einer meiner
lieblingsserie um einstein einstein was
ist es nur gut für einsteiger hatte mal
eine richtige fußball supercup 2006
kennt wahrscheinlich eine andere von
euch war echt geil und ich glaube dass
gerade gar nicht mehr kennt wen.de
gucken so nächste frage wie oft hatte
ich schon eine gehirnerschütterung war
ich irgendwo gegen gelaufen oder
irgendwo runtergefallen bin fünf mal wo
er weiter weil du damals in berlin bei
der fussball dingens geführt zweimal
gegen erschütterungen oder eltern
zweimal jeder schützen einmal dahin
gehende woche später dann wieder gut ist
eine ganz neue ablösen
also du müsstest jetzt einem echten
machen dass du also die hälfte
reduzierte wind aber fünfmal stimmt ich
bin echt fand einmal wenn ich den banken
auch der mögliche schule liegende tür
gelaufen dann bin ich von der schub
herren gefallen
dann bin ich und wahrscheinlich noch mal
gegen die wand gelaufen hatte schon
früher man die bühne wo ich das erzählt
habe
aber vielleicht weckt das weist auf die
stimmten dinge die mir passiert nächste
frage wie groß bin ich weil ich da nicht
ein sie nach eingelassen der wahrheit
184 kann man ja auch nicht verschätzt
und weist auch das zwei meter 1 58 also
so möchte frage was mit sport mein
lieblingsfach in der schule deutsch
deutsch mein deutsch nicht aber kunst
auch mal witzig weiteres zustimmen mal
gesagt was wahr nicht immer cool so bis
zur ersten kraft wird das einst das
leider nicht mehr verdrängt mit predigt
mio
5 zu 2 es sind gar nicht gut aus 44
hatte doch immer alles gut und
philosophie oder ich kann ja viel uns
viele punkte für so viel spaß gemacht
war ich das erste mal betrunken war auch
traurig kommen machen erstmal sparen
sagen was er zum punkt so eine noch
gewinnen konnten
drei der zumindest leistung nicht zur
frage wie viele abonnenten habe ich auf
youtube 5000 ja ein gleichstand von als
nicht leicht im jahr 1953 nächste frage
dass mit der pistole geschossen kommt
vorbei klima und war wie heißt mein
youtube-channel eigentlich 18 16 nein
keine zeit lässt ev stv
das heißt jemand einen stand von 50 euro
kann zum laichen lassen wenn der
absoluten master frage die sich jetzt
nicht auf mich beziehen sondern die ich
jetzt einfach auf den kopf nehmen weil
ich immer sehr gut in mathe war und zwar
was ist 12 x 12
dann will ich sagen er ist eine master
frage wo sich um den gewinn geht so sehr
wir brauchen ja gewinner wir kommen zur
ultimativen extrem universum einfach zu
letzten tage und war war mein abi
durchschnitt 14 glückwunsch eigentlich
hast du jetzt wir wollen aber ein ich
hab ja weiter sechs punkte deswegen
würde ich mal sagen ihr könnt mich
weiter gleich schlecht ja leute die
haben keine beschreibung
mir einfach jetzt seit man gleich an
beide kennen sich seit gut wie gesagt
ich hoffe dass wieder alles gefallen
wenn öfter mal wieder zu einem bruder
kommen da hat man dann nach oben da weil
ich habe ja schon mal nicht mehr mit
irgendwas in salmünster fasst man steckt
auf jeden fall die klamotten abbild ich
mega freuen schauten shop vorbei geht
auf instagram last auf jeden fall ein
toller job und wir sehen uns morgen
häufig wieder morgen abend 19 uhr und
sonntag weil ich auch noch was sagen zum
abschluss wer macht die besten klamotten
der welt
die marke heißt übrigens war 20 euro
oder so für den hier nicht ob ich glaube
ich würde ihnen hier an ideen konnte die
übungs 075 euro
wer könnte glaube ich 95 euro weil es
halt mit kapuze also alles auf jeden
fall ich will jetzt gar keine werbung
machen dafür da so aber mache